دكتوره ليلى يعني امس بالاحتفالات احلى ما
يعني لفتني شخصيا هو الازياء
القديمه الاصيله اخبرينا عن رحله تطور
الازياء السعوديه التقليديه
[موسيقى]
تطور
حاصل في جميع
الازمان والاماكن وبالتالي فان ازياءنا
تطورت عبر الازمنه والقرون وهي
تتاثر بتاثر وتطور صناعه المنسوجات
والازياء
اللي حاصله في العالم كله هذا ينعكس على
تطور الازياء التقليديه في المملكه
اعتمدت الازياء التقليديه على استيراد
المنسوجات من دول العالم المشهوره بهذه
المنسوجات سواء من الصين او الهند او من
الدول العربيه القريبه من الجزيره العربيه
واللي كانت مشهوره بالمنسوجات مثل العراق
وبلاد الشام ومصر
واخذت ملابسنا التقليديه في مناطق المملكه
مختلفه طابعها الخاص فيها
ونستطيع التعرف على كل منطقه من خلال الزي
سواء للرجل او المراه
ويتضح هذا التنوع بشده في المنطقه الغربيه
في عند قبائل الحجاز فهي منطقه
تميز ازيائها
نسائيه المراه من من اي قبيله بحيث انه
اذا شفنا الزي نستطيع ان نتعرف على
ان المراه من كيف يعني يمكن تمييز هذه
الاختلافات يعني هل من طريقه وضع الشيله
هل من خلال التطريز
من خلال عوامل كثيره من اهمها طبعا
الزخرفه والتطريز كل امراه بالرغم القرب
الجغرافي لقبائل الحجاز الا ان كل امراه
تميزت باسلوبها الزخرفي لثوبها وهي اكثر
منطقه يمكن ما تاثرت بالعوامل الخارجيه
لانه نجد ان المناطق اللي موجوده على حدود
المملكه تاثرت بالبلدان المجاوره لها
والمناطق اللي موجوده على السواحل البحريه
تاثرت بالتجاره اللي جتها من الهند او من
غيرها من البلاد المجاوره فنجد المنطقه
الشرقيه تاثرت في دول الخليج وفي الهند
بينما
المنطقه الشماليه تاثرت ببلاد الشام
والعراق وسط الجزيره العربيه اكثر محافظه
على
ازياءه وله شخصيه المستقله وكذلك مثل ما
ذكرنا
نجد من الاماكن اللي تاثرت بالعوامل
الخارجيه
اكثر شيء بلاد
الحرمين
الحجاج والمعتمرين واستقرارهم من شعوب
مختلفه استقروا في هذه المنطقه وكونوا
سه
رت سواء بالاكل او باللبس مع بعضها البعض
وكونت ثقافه جديده لهذه الشعوب اللي
استقرت في المنطقه وصار لها شخصيتها كذلك
المميزه ماذا عن اللباس التراثي السعودي
للرجل يعني كم تطور ايضا
اللباس لباس الرجل كان لكل منطقه لبسها
المميز ولكن باتحاد المملكه
وبدخول الرجل للاعمال الحكوميه
اضطر انه
يلبس اللبس السعودي الموحد فظهر الرجل
بلبس سعودي
متشابه في جميع المناطق ولكن الرجل تميز
عن المراه بمحافظته على زي التقليدي فنجد
ان الرجل استمر في استخدام الزياده
التقليدي مهما طرا عليه من
تحديث وتجديد
دون ان يتوقف عن استخدامه بينما المراه مع
النهضه اللي حصلت في المملكه بعد اكتشاف
البترول وقدوم الاجانب للمنطقه
وسهوله السفر والاختلاط بالشعوب الاخرى
تغيرت ملابسها تماما وتركت الزي التقليدي
واتجهت للازياء الحديثه المستورده ولكن
خيره وجدنا عوده للتراث خاصه في المناسبات
الوطنيه وفي المناسبات الدينيه عادت
المراه لارتداء الثوب التقليدي وعاد
الاهتمام له
اكثر والان نجد الاهتمام اكثر واكثر
بتشجيع الجهات المسؤوله على ارتداء هذه
الازياء في المناسبات المهمه مثل ما نشوف
في اليوم الوطني في ذكرى تاسيس في مهرجان
الفروسيه
وغيرها من المنى
زنق واوجد عند المواطنين حب عوده لهذا
التراث والتمسك به والبحث عنه يعني يجيني
كثير استفسارات من جهات مختلفه يحبون
يتاكدون هل هذا الزي صحيح يسالون عن ملابس
منطقتهم في الناس صار عندها
فضول واهتمام لمعرفه ملابسها اكثر واكثر
وصار عندها اهتمام انها تصحح المفاهيم
المغلوطه عن هذه الملابس وتلبس
يعني الالوان معروف بانه ازياء السعودي
للمراه لونه اسود لون قاتم ولكن يعني من
شاهد انه في ازياء احيانا ملونه هل ذلك
يتعارض مع الهويه الاصيله
المفهوم هذا غلط مئه بالمئه لانه فهم من
خلال العبائها العباءه هي اللي سوداء ولكن
ما تحت العباءه كان ملون بجميع الالوان
المراه النجديه كانت تحب الالوان
صارخه نوعا ما او
الزاهيه مثل الفوشيا والاخضر الفستقي
والاحمر العنابي والبرتقالي
كانت تحب انها تضيف التطريز بكثافه على
ملابسها كان فيه نوع من الثياب اسمه الثوب
المتبثه والمجرحه والمبدح كان يتميز بوجود
ثلاثه الوان مضافه من الحرير بشكل هندسي
تزين هذا النوع من الثياب بالاضافه
للتطريز
فعلا الثياب كانت ملونه وكانت بهيجه منطقه
الحجاز تختلف عن منطقه نجد حبهم للون
الابيض بينما نجد ان نجد تعتبر اللون
الابيض تشبه بالرجال لذلك سالتك دكتوره
ليلى لتصحيح هذه المعلومه والالوان شكرا
جزيلا لك اذا من الرياض خبيره التراث
واستاذه الازياء والمنسوجات التقليديه
الدكتوره ليلى البس ام